yes we are getting festive here at las
vegas now so the holidays just aren't
complete without music good food and
good company and you can get all of that
on december 10th at an intimate holiday
affair with kelly clinton at the
sterling club and we are so excited to
be joined by kelly clinton herself to
give us all the festive details thank
you for being here thank you for having
me an intimate holiday affair it sounds
scandalous doesn't it it does it does
sound scandalous but i think it's going
to be more fun than anything tell us
about it i hear there's a lot of food
involved too oh there's food that i
can't even you know i don't even know
how to say it it's like a five course
dinner with delicious desserts and um
the entertainment that's that's where i
know what i'm talking about with
entertainment we're putting on a show
and we're combining the beautiful
elegant sterling club and the
traditional holiday music and some
non-traditional holiday music as well
and we have friends joining us to sing
with us
but we really want everyone to come and
see how beautiful the sterling club is
members and people who aren't members
are welcome to to be a part of this and
i have some special guests if you want
to know who they are
yes i might have a guest but i will let
you tell us who your special guests are
i'm going to tell you about that guy
first okay i'm going to tell you about
some other interesting beautiful
talented people um and then i'll hit you
with the big name all right let's do it
so um a girl who's like just six foot
tall absolutely gorgeous and a voice
just amazing someone says is it mariah
carey and i said it's it's even more
than mariah her name is ashley fuller
okay and she is so talented good friend
of ours and uh lanny counts who can sing
anything he can sing the phone book
r b and classical everything and jerry
jones our very good friend and they're
going to join us and then there's this
one guy who is so hard for me to get in
touch with his name is clint holmes oh
and he's my husband so he has to come to
the show he has no choice right
that's what he says he goes well i
didn't really have a choice but he i'm a
guest in his show this weekend and then
that night on december 10th at the
sterling club he's my guest and and it's
just going to be great this sounds like
so much fun and i have to say i grew up
here in las vegas you and clint have
just been such a staple in our community
and always giving back and entertaining
everyone how does it feel to be back on
stage we were just talking about
thanksgiving and everyone can be
together again it has to just be the
best feeling yeah absolutely i mean for
all of us everyone no matter what you do
for a living but as entertainers singers
it was very hard to not we have an
audience and and i remember the first
show back i i did one show in july and
it was like so emotional and that's how
this feels it feels like we're back at
the sterling club one of our favorite
places in the whole world and uh we're
blessed we're blessed and we want to
take advantage of this and have you all
come join us and
again the food is unbelievable are you
going to show the menu yes i was looking
at the menu earlier and one thing
sounded better than the next i can't
wait to come out and try it and then
pair that with some great entertainment
it's going to be a perfect night and if
people want to get tickets where do they
go let's give them all the information
sterlingclub.com and like i said you
don't have to be a member you can be a
guest and come to the show and i believe
it's 150 dollars for members and 175 for
non-members but we're going to promise
you an evening of delicious food and and
a lot of fun by the way it's not just
traditional holiday music there's
there's going to be some humor and some
surprises
a little bit of everything you don't let
us down
well there's all the information on your
screen mark your calendars for december
10th 6 30 p.m at the sterling club happy
holidays